DONATED MONEY TO BUILD THE RUN
BABY RUN GYM.
>> Jim: TRACY.
>> Tracy: COACH, THIS TEAM IS
GETTING BETTER AND BETTER, AND
WHAT HAVE YOU SEEN?
>> THEY OUTPLAYED US IN THE
SECOND HALF TO GET IT TO FIVE,
AND OF THE TIME-OUT, WE WERE A
DIFFERENT TEAM.
GOING ZONE HELPED US.
BUT WE SCORED TWO STRAIGHT TIMES
AND THAT WAS BIG.
>> Tracy: YOU TALKED ABOUT US
WANTING THIS SO BAD FOR THE
TEAM, AND GIVING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY.
>> YEAH, WE CALL IT CROSSING THE
BRIDGE.
THERE IS NOTHING LIKE BEING A
REGIONAL CHAMP AND GOING TO
FINAL FOUR AND PLAYING ON THAT
SATURDAY WITH THREE OTHER
CHAMPIONS AND IT IS AN AMAZING
DAY.
>> Tracy: I KNOW THERE IS
EMOTION, BUT FOR YOU TO CONTINUE
THIS FINAL RUN ON THE SEASON --